a federal judges temporarily blocked
President Trump from ending the daca
program that protects young young legal
illegal rather immigrants who grew up in
the u.s. from deportation
last night's ruling helps daca
supporters who were suing to preserve
the program now earlier in the day the
president talked about immigration with
members of Congress from both parties in
a rare move the White House press pool
was allowed to show that discussion
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with that story Margaret good morning
good morning well it was an
extraordinary decision for the president
to allow reporters to watch him
negotiate for nearly an hour this is
perhaps a gesture to quiet those
questions about his mental stability but
he also demonstrated that he wants to
strike the type of sweeping immigration
reform that has eluded the last two
presidents President Trump said he wants
quote a bill of love but it also has to
be a bill where we're able to secure our
border and offer to reverse his decision
to end daca to be a clean bill is a bill
of daca we take care of them and we also
take care of security if lawmakers agree
to a sweeping overhaul of immigration
and border security I will be signing it
I'm not going to say oh gee I want this
I want that I'll be signing it in
exchange the president wants to end the
visa lottery limit immigration based on
family ties and secure funding to build
a wall on the southern border they can
go up quickly it can go up effectively
and we can fix a lot of the areas right
now Democrats want to push off border
wall talks until after the status of the
daca recipients is handled an idea
Republican Kevin McCarthy objected to
when we talk about just daca we don't
want to be back here two years later the
president also surprised lawmakers by
announcing his ultimate goal what
another truth dick if we do this
properly daca you're not so far away
from comprehensive immigration reform
passing comprehensive immigration reform
which could give millions of
undocumented immigrants a path to
citizenship I don't care I don't care
I'll take all the heat you want to give
and I'll take the heat off both the
Democrats and the Republicans my whole
life has been heat I like you in a
certain way but I will I mean you are
somewhat more traditional politicians
than me that offers citizenship or at
least legal status for undocumented
immigrants is an dramatic change for a
platform that the president ran on which
was a hard-line immigration stance now
he avoided in the room any details any
specifics at least while cameras were
there but Gail allowing those cameras to
film for an hour is unprecedented that
was a very interesting conversation
yesterday thank you very much Margaret
to be continued for sure